what i would like to explore in this
video is to see if we could figure out
what the derivative of y is with respect
to x if y
is equal to the inverse sine
the inverse sine of x
and like always i encourage you to pause
this video and try to figure this out on
your own and i will give you two hints
first hint is well we don't know what
the derivative of sine inverse of x is
but we do know what the size what the
derivative of the sine of something is
and so if you maybe if you rearrange
this and use some implicit
differentiation maybe you can figure out
what d y d x is remember this right over
here this right over here is our goal we
essentially want to figure out the
derivative of this with respect to x
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it so
let's work through this together
so if y is the inverse sine of x that's
just like saying that that's equivalent
to saying that sine of y
sine of y
is equal to x
sine of y is equal to x
so now we have things that we're a
little bit more familiar with and now we
can do a little bit of implicit
differentiation we could take the
derivative of both sides with respect to
x
so derivative of the left-hand side with
respect to x and the derivative of the
right-hand side with respect to x
well what's the derivative of the
left-hand side with respect to x going
to be and here we just apply the chain
rule it's going to be the derivative of
sine of y with respect to y
which is going to be which is going to
be cosine
of y
times the derivative of y with respect
to x so times d y d x
times
d y
d x
and the right hand side what's the
derivative of x with respect to x
well that's obviously just going to be
equal to 1.
and so we could solve for d y d x divide
both sides by cosine of y and we get the
derivative of y
with respect to x is equal to 1
over cosine of y
now this still isn't that satisfying
because i have the derivative in terms
of y so let's see if we can re-express
it in terms of x so how could we do that
well we already know that x is equal to
sine of y let me rewrite it we already
know that x is equal to sine
of y so if we can rewrite this bottom
expression in terms instead of cosine of
y if we could use our trigonometric
identities to rewrite it in terms of
sine of y then we'll be in good shape
because x is equal to sine of y
well how can we do that well we know
from our trigonometric identities we
know
that sine
squared of y plus cosine squared of y is
equal to 1.
or if we want to solve for cosine of y
subtract sine squared of y from both
sides we know that cosine squared of y
is equal to 1 minus sine
squared of y or that cosine of y just
take the principal root of both sides is
equal to the principal root of 1 minus
sine squared of
y
so we can rewrite this as being equal to
1 over
1 over instead of cosine of y we could
rewrite it as
1 minus sine squared of y
now why is this useful well sine of y is
just x so this is the same if we just
substitute back in and let me just write
it that way so it's a little bit clear i
could write it as sine y
squared we know that this thing right
over here is x so this is going to be
equal to and we deserve a little bit of
a drum roll
1 over the square root
of 1 minus instead of sine of y we know
that x is equal to sine of y
so 1 minus x squared and so there you
have it the derivative with respect to x
of the inverse sine
of x
is equal to
is equal to 1
over the square root of 1 minus x
squared so let me just make that very
clear if you take the derivative with
respect to x of both sides of this you
would get d y d x is equal to
this on the right hand side or we could
say the derivative with respect to x
of the inverse sine of x is equal to
over the square root
of 1 minus x squared now you could
always reprove this if your memory
starts to fail you and actually that is
the best way to really internalize this
but this is also just a good thing to
know especially as we start as we go
into more and more calculus and you see
you might see this in expression you
might say okay that's the derivative of
the inverse sine of x which might prove
to be useful